i mean did that shock would that worry
you at all were you were you like
why am i deleting this or are you just
like i'm at work and i'm gonna delete
all these guys you know
some people enjoyed it i mean if yeah
i'm sure they did
they enjoyed the power the power trip um
but even we even had a picture of uh
george soros's son that people are
confusing with the ukraine whistleblower
and i raised that up
and i asked my supervisors they said
they said uh and they asked facebook
actually or i think
and they said no still delete it because
they're implying that it's him
so it wasn't even him it was someone
else it was alexander soros
i i fooled around a bit on facebook to
see what i can get away with
of course he did and uh i did one post
that was like
i wrote this thing which was basically
i wrote a short paragraph saying why
censorship is wrong but the first letter
of each
word spelled his name going straight
down pretty much yeah i had seen those
ones
it never got deleted no yes i think i
saw it on it
maybe they deleted as you didn't notice
at this point but it was up for a really
really long time as far as i know
and i thought it was gonna be temporary
i'm like okay yeah it's trending right
now maybe in a couple months
but i checked back and that was like in
october or november i checked back in
january and up until i i left till the
project ended in this past february
that guidance was still active you want
to know what the craziest thing was one
of my posts
i s we'll just call this guy jondo uh no
i call him voldemort we'll call him
voldemort
he who must not be named yeah we can't
so uh i i made a post
using his real name of course but it
said voldermort is a 55 year old dental
hygienist
from you know dubuque iowa he has a he
has a family a wife and five kids
and he's gonna you know something really
benign and having nothing to do with
anything
they deleted it just because that
name was in it even though it was a text
post
about a dental hygienist in debut
totally different person
gone now that was over the top i was
like wow
yeah it's like it almost felt like it
was a robot doing it but
it was people yeah there really could be
someone with that name
who has happened to have the same name
as him who's getting
punished because of it it's speaking of
attacking innocent people
and unlike the the average joe citizen
uh
you know who caitlyn bennett is right
yes so there was a meme
that's trending about her that's still
trending of her like passed out drunk
supposedly it was her
and there was like feces coming out it
was really gross she made a mess
yeah so they still to this day she's
that realistic i don't know is it real
that's what we were debating and that's
kind of discussions we have weird
conversations at facebook like it sounds
like it just a quick
aside you know that the melania trump
nude photo like
where she's like crouched to crotch with
another female we we had this huge
discussion about that because
per facebook posse if they're crotch on
crotch and and some one of them doesn't
have underwear on
if it's a guy and a girl well you know
there could be uh
yeah for sake of a better word
penetration i'm trying to speak about it
scientifically be a little family
friendly yeah
um and so we were we ended up
interpreting the policy to delete that
because
anyways it was just kind of weird but
it's you know two females next to each
other that's weird yeah
um so back to caitlin bennett so caitlyn
bennett yeah there's this meme
trending about her you know passed out
drunk but you can't see her face
so there's there's some college co-ed
face down and her friends are standing
around and she's past the drunk and
there's
stuff coming out of her backside and her
skirts pulled up
halfway like halfway up her buttocks and
so
there's three different policies that
that would we'd look at in this
situation so the first is the
bullying policy so first of all i see a
public figure or private individual we
don't know
but the policy says we don't know if
it's a public figure or private
then we default to private individual to
protect the private individual
so they should not done that from the
get-go there's another policy called
sexual exploitation of adults
that covers creep shots or taking
pictures of people when they're
passed out half naked that makes sense
yeah and so like there's clear
clearly a lot of things they could have
deleted this for um
but yeah but they said but the guidance
was and i have a screenshot of the
guidance they said
well we don't know but we kind of think
that that is true so
leave it up so you couldn't even see
what it was you couldn't tell what it
was and the specific guidance in the
letter of the law was to
default to private individual if you're
unsure default to private individuals so
they
they didn't follow the their own policy
which you as you can see is a trend
facebook not following their own rules
yeah and so they
yeah they left it up so that could be
some innocent you know 19 year old girl
who's now
you know being made fun of nationally
well yeah that's that's
what they always say about caitlyn
bennett and i i didn't know anything
about what it was they were just you
know they
they make fun of her so this could be
just entirely made up
to go after her to try and poison the
well discredit her so that she can't
speak
and facebook allows it to happen in
violation of their own rules right
amazing have you seen other any other
examples like that or was that
so that was a big one i think um i think
also with uh greta thunderberg
um you know she's i think she's she does
a lot of good work i think she's a
wonderful person i mean
but you know she's uh she has been
really cool you ridiculed a lot so
facebook gave her
a um it gave an exception to give her
additional protections
and we know she there's so many you know
autism i think and so i want to be
respectful of that as well
i think she's 17 now or she i'm not sure
17 or 18 18. but anyway so people were
calling her
[ __ ] and this is after that incident
at the u.n where there was exchange
in exchange between credit thunderbird
and donald trump but people are calling
her
[ __ ] gree [ __ ] yeah yeah
uh and so it's kind of a playoff
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so minor public figures like her they do
have some protections like you can't
make sexual jokes about them because
they are minors
but you can call you can call a minor
you can stop you can call jojo siwa
a [ __ ] like you can tell you call
anybody else who's a minor public figure
[ __ ] it's not a nice thing to say but
facebook allows it because it's nothing
it's not sexual in nature but facebook
made an exception to
disallow and delete any mention of greta
thunder
and so that's when they use their
proactive pool again their ai scraped
the system
and dumped all instances of greta
thunder into our queue even the actual
post we had on our workplace that was
mentioning
[ __ ] it pulled that same uh
post into our queue so every day we're
deleting hundreds of jobs related to
that so it's one example of them kind of
making exception to the rules to protect
very certain people
very clearly protecting the left and
going after the right right
so uh well i asked you twice now that
you you think they did
provide a benefit to the democrats help
them win essentially in 2018
yeah i did 100 do you think that's
what's happening now
100 i mean like the yeah and like a lot
all the evidence i have points towards
that
um yeah that they are like interfering
the election i have this these notes
here so this is
what they did for the 2020 elections
they created a new queue
so it's called the civic harassment
queue and so they combined basically
hate speech and bullying
in a way but they're saying they said
why were the changes made to the
existing guided review tree for bullying
harassment
and they said bullying harassment has
been identified as a priority issue
around the us 2020 election
we acknowledge that anyone can share an
opinion about the us 2020 election
but not all voices carry equally far nor
are equally susceptible to attacks
we want to protect not only influential
figures who are vulnerable to harassment
through their status but also ordinary
folks that make themselves vulnerable by
interacting with content generated by
these figures
so they're saying there's this overlap
between like hate speech and like the
election
so what happened was we ended up getting
i think they usually
really wanted to see what what was
trending so i saw dc drano's instagram
account a lot
some of these huge uh instagram
influencers so
more things got reported in those
comments and and so i think they just
really wanted to see the trends
uh but yeah it was always a priority
they're
when they track the trends it's giving
them intelligence on what's going on and
how people think and feel when it comes
to
uh elections and politics yeah you know
i'm i'm curious because i know that mark
zuckerberg had
apparently had a private meeting with i
think like trump and ben shapiro and
some other people or something
i'm wondering if they realized that a
lot of people were mentioning
if the republicans win and they're not
censoring republicans
they'll probably be fine because the
conservatives rarely want to regulate
big companies in fact there's a lot of
conservatives right now saying no it's a
free speech thing we don't want to
regulate
if the left wins even if they support
them they're going to regulate antitrust
or whatever
so a lot of people were suggesting that
mark zuckerberg at some point realized
the trend
that free speech you know
liberals were joining conservatives and
defending you know free speech
and these values and then mark
zuckerberg switched to start defending
the right
so now we have uh there's there's two
big stories that
overlap one is that facebook recently
was de-ranking
progressive websites like think progress
and that they and that actively helping
in in a way
conservative sites and that's why
conservative sites are now
the top 10 most shared or engaged with
content
every single week you can see it's like
fox news ben shapiro dan bongino
every single time so i'm curious if if
you saw
it it doesn't sound like you saw
anything but i'm wondering if you saw
any kind of shift in that capacity
if there's any veracity to that theory
so from a business standpoint obviously
it makes sense to side with
people who are more more you know
towards free speech or more libertarians
who want less government involvement
because the last thing
facebook wants is more government
regulation right
you know i asked a lot of people at
facebook my co-workers like hey what are
what are facebook motives are they
are they political and they're like well
that's all about the money for them
so i think there's some validity to that
i know uh mark zuckerberg
zuckerberg got a lot of flack when he
said about a year ago
he said that we're not going to fact
check political ads
yeah and the left like destroyed him oh
and then he met with trump and now
they're banning trump's ads
yeah so they finally flip-flopped yup
and
i have some personal experience with
that when i worked at uber corporate in
2016 as a contractor
i worked as a fraud analyst uh live for
about two months
and we we had this this club meeting
with called uber hugh
like uh like the ebony club from high
school whatever but it's called uber
hugh
and one of the leaders was like bragging
about how they got
travis kalanick the ceo of uber to
retract his statement of all lives
matter
wow and so she was like bragging about
i'm like and then she's like yeah and
then he donated
and this uh something to the fourth
fourth floor of the seer center in
in sacramento for that was dedicated to
the black panthers and i'm like
so you're admitting that like black
lives matter like helped
like forced him to retract statement
like that's kind of messed up
um so yeah as far as yeah with mark
zuckerberg and this trend up so i did
notice a lot of changes after the civic
audit
so the civic audit from the covington
law firm with former senator john kyle
started in about may of 2018 right after
the
yeah what is this this lawsuit yeah so
um basically
i think there was pressure from congress
obviously because zuckerberg had just
testified in april of 2018
and so there was this claim that
conservatives were being censored so
this independent law firm covington
headed by former uh arizona senator john
kyle
basically went in and interviewed a
bunch of people working at facebook and
tried to
validify these claims
and so they found that yeah there was
somebody to them and so i saw
a change after that so after that point
then they began tracking the the news
were the exceptions they began
being a little more careful about what
they said i saw less more blatant
leftist leaning posts um but as to your
question as far as
you know what market works strategy is
or if he's now
leaning to the right i mean like from a
business standpoint like i say i mean
it's it's possible um that he's he's
trying to play both sides yeah but i
think it definitely i think there's too
much pressure from these organizations
on the left
i mean if you can have the uber ceo
retract his statement because of
pressure from black lives matter
i think there's too much social pressure
from the left
so it's gonna always lean that way
based on what you were saying did it
feel like you know there were a lot of
people
who like what was there more of that you
saw right wing or left-wing content
i would say there's more right-wing
content um i saw a lot of posts
i did see you know on was it now now
this
you know this politics a lot and i saw
do you see drano a lot
um what's dc drano he's right-wing yeah
okay he's
yeah he's in florida he's he's got about
a million followers on instagram oh wow
he's a huge office right i'm not sure
he might be uh i know he's a big trump
supporter um
so so yeah there's a lot of
i saw more right-wing content there was
a fair mix i would say
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you